hey welcome to a new project cam video
so we bought this piece of land and are
prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's gonna go but let's see
and in the previous update you've seen
me showing some of the basic
infrastructure currently being used
that's a poop hole it's very basic but
today we're actually going to add a
piece of infrastructure
because matia is dropping by with this
beautiful yellow cubicle van
[Music]
so if you studied the original project
cam drawing well
you could see right there in the little
corner is the italian guy in his yellow
van
which is this one right here in real
life
all right hey mattia yo yo hello dave
what's happening
so you've been living in this van for a
while yeah this is a
well i call this home for the past five
years so about uh
early 2016 i was uh
living i broke up actually with max
girvin and then i thought
you know what i might as well just uh
try to live in a van and see what it's
like
and since then i've been doing slow uh
little improvements
uh month after month week after week and
uh
and now yeah now it's been five years
that i'm full time
well actually more on and off living in
this van
and yeah i can just show you around if
you want because now you don't live in
it anymore now you have in porto yeah so
now i
we just arrived here with uh katy my
wife
we just arrived in december november and
we decided to spend winter in
porto because well it rains a lot here
today doesn't look like but it's uh
it's very wet and it rains a lot and
there's no electricity and we have
a lot of things to do so we decided to
just uh
go back to normal civilized life so that
we can get more
more work done more more more [ __ ] than
can we see the inside
so now the inside is a bit empty because
uh yeah now it's really empty
because all my stuff is an apartment but
yeah i can explain
how how this works so
yeah welcome so let's start from the
most important part which is the bed
and this is a foldable bed and i think
over the time is
to me that's the most smart way of
utilizing space because when you're not
sleeping you just
close it up here and then you have all
this space that otherwise will be taken
up by a bed
which you use only for eight hours and
the rest of the time
uh you really don't over there you have
like a more
my closet you have a lot of some clothes
there are a few shells that's where we
keep all the stuff and over here is the
kitchen area and sink so here is where
we cook a bit here normally it's full of
like spices and
beans and whatever like storage here is
more storage
and here is a one of the best this made
my life for
a couple of months i was just flying
because this small thing just changed my
complete life
one life and it's basically a water pump
and you just press there and then you
have like running water in your van
which is uh from this bubble there on
this big
old wine bottle this is a 25 liter
jar where my friend julio stores the
wine and sells this wine
and then you know this is maybe 30 years
old so it's really sturdy really really
hard
and also we don't i don't store water in
plastic so here is
stored in glass which i don't know feels
better for me
but mainly it's like this uh this foot
pump which is uh i don't know i really
enjoyed at that time
i'm looking forward to uh be excited
about it here yeah
so this one was a german post van
so used to deliver packages across
berlin and then
and then here we have like this big
space which is empty
which is very nice when you live in a
small space and also i should mention
that
for the past two years we've been living
here in two me and my wife cathy
so you really have to maximize space and
how to uh
yeah use it as best where do you sit
so we have a chairs and we have like a
couple of pillows on the floor as well
uh work from the floor or here so here
normally we have a chair and we just
work
from our laptop here and we're just
outside
in summer we use the outside space and
here is the latest
sort of more again space optimization
where
we put all the food and more um
yeah just like to store
stuff i guess and here
also yeah
latest sort of geek out
the solar system and we just want to be
pro
and with this we can run our uh
our blender so we make we can make
juices all our
laptops we have two labs that we work uh
remotely so always on the computer so
eight hours a day plugged in so why do
you not have your panel on the roof
well so we just got it last summer and
we were in italy so [ __ ] hot
and we thought if you want to have it on
top you need to have your van in the sun
all the time
however that means it's very hot so we
kind of wanted to be free
from that so we wanted to have the van
in the shade and then the solar in the
sun so we
thought of like getting this 10 15
meters of cable so we can put this panel
in the sun
and keep the van in the in the shadow
and of course we're gonna build this
frame and everything but for now
and then everyone online you stupid
shy
and what do you have under the hood
which one
under the hood like the motor uh
wait a minute it's a mercedes okay
now usually people say it's like 2.5 uh
it's a motor i don't give a [ __ ] it's
just a motor that takes me around
i don't know what it is i think it's two
point something
but i'm i'm really not a technical guy
oh this is a nice thing but i don't know
it's a
vegan proof when i found this one i just
also
next day i encountered this splashed
frog
and i kept it there ever since as a sort
of a sign of
good luck death proof
gadgets yeah the coaster
yeah he's been there he's been with me
for all five years so
thank you buddy did every anything bad
happen to you like maybe someone
oh you mentioned some no one got stolen
anything but
stuff breaking or people harassing you
when you're sleeping
in cities or too cold or stuff is frozen
or wet or
yeah well you have a lot of these uh
experiences and sometimes it's freaking
cold and
but you go through and then you know it
makes you
yeah stronger to the cold or something
and yeah sometimes we have
we had a police couple of times knocking
in the netherlands actually
uh saying that you couldn't sleep and
then yeah just start again and you stop
in the next
parking lot or the next forest or
whatever
but no no never never like moment that
you're scared or anything
more like funny stories to tell um
yeah and it's more like elaborating on
the reason why i started to live in a
van which for me is the most important
thing
which is back in 2016 i just graduated
graduated from university
and yeah i just didn't want to get a
normal job to
work for this big advertising machine or
this big
sort of capitalistic machine where you
know you put in time
to make people buy more stuff or want
more stuff
and so i i had it very clear for myself
that i wanted to work on more
sustainable projects or projects that do
have another goal another meaning
and but then naturally this project they
tend to be
uh financially less remunerated like
having less
budget less money less salaries so for
me it was very clear that i wanted to
work on these projects
and consequentially it's also hard to
live a
classic normal lifestyle where you have
a flat where you have all these expenses
when you start the month
we already like a thousand years to pay
between insurances and flats and
and bills so for me at a time
the solution to these to be able to do
this project was to
cut my costs as much as possible so i
just bought a van
went start living in a van and suddenly
from one month to another i had
you know an average i had like 100 euro
cost
of my living which was basically paying
for insurance of a van which is you know
kind of cheap
and that enabled me to start working on
precious plastic and to keep on
working on projects that are not
necessarily commercially driven
because i had very little costs
what are you making definitely i'm
warming up
what we're just making a little path to
go from there
from the little camp to the kitchen and
we can wait
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
all right hey hello everyone so last
time dave was showing you the path up
until here and today i'm going to show
you the last part that we just
finished to cut that will take us from
the kitchen to the camp so just to recap
the original route we made
in update 2 you can see here and today
we added this little piece right here in
the blue line
so we don't have to take the big road
anymore so the new route is going to be
like this
so we can walk up this is the main road
that you are most familiar with by now
i'm sure
going up you go to the camp and you
could go there fast with your car or run
but if you take this little sidewalk
you get onto one of the main fields
that leads into the kitchen
one of the few trees
so kitchen right there
massive field
lots of things that we can do there and
yeah from here we just
cut ourselves a little puff so that we
can get to our little
base camp exactly
paint tree kitchen
stores everywhere
[Music]
all right
you can really imagine in summer how
this forest will be
a nice refuge from the sun
because it's nice and cool
i still need to make a stairs here yes
for the grandma's
and you know the camp here is where
we're going to be
creating the base camp with the vans and
the containers
very soon what you're building
a fire or actually a wood drying machine
could we call it a camp
fire we can call it a campfire but i
think it's project camp
yeah good job cam zero
but i think it's mainly just drying the
wood because it's so wet
you can it's so [ __ ]
yeah it's true no it's wet and rainy
here my god man
it's outrageous it wasn't lying it's
outrageously
wet
you oh my god
yes the day has come i'm gonna leave
behind my
my yellow love and make sure that dave
has a living room i can enjoy some extra
space
and then later on yeah come back so
what's your
way of transportation now i have to
drive you everywhere uh yeah
basically i just call uh uber dave and i
just kind of drops by
picks me up gets my [ __ ]
all right yeah saturday sad days
all right so now there is an extra
little kitchen on the camp where we can
properly
cook store our spices store our food
we have a bit more storage space so it's
actually really nice having this around
uh yeah that was it for this update if
you want to see more updates make sure
to go here
and if you want to see all the future
updates that are yet to come make sure
to subscribe
so you get notified when there is one
well i guess you know how subscribing
works
and if you want to help us out and make
sure we can continue development
make sure to visit
support.projectcomp.com to see how you
can help out
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update